はい よろしくお願いします
今日はヴィパッサナー瞑想の悟りの智慧の段階を喋っているところで
二番目 三番目まで行きましたと思いますけど
293ページの 三十番目は一応終わりました
今日は三十一のこのカンカー・ヴィターラナ・ヴィスッディということ
ヴィパッサナーっていうのは智慧を開発する瞑想ですから
別に何か経験 経験 経験ということではないんです
ですからこの いろいろ智慧開発したっても経験と全く引き離れているわけではないんだから
でも経験を大事にするんじゃなくて
あなたは何を学んだかっていうことは大事にするんですね
ですから いろいろ経験というものはね
瞑想の世界で出てくる可能性はありますけど
そちらには全然条件を入れないです
だから人に教える時も
これからこの智慧に頑張ってください
この智慧を開発してくださいと言ったっても
それもまた全く無意味なことで
ですから たまたまこれからこうなるだろうと経験の世界のことを言いますけどね
それですごく威張って
すぐにさらざらとその前に言った経験を並べてこちらに言い返してくれるんですね
それでチェックしたら何も学んでないということは嘘を言ってるんです
こういうことはありました
こういうことはありましたと言ったとしてもね
無常を見えましたとかね
そうやって騙すことはできないんです
その瞬間で確かめてみるんです
だから瞑想最中では私にはいろいろ無常見えますからと言われた瞬間で何かちょっと違う関係ないこと言ってみるんですね
聞いた途端腹が立って
で 随分徹底した固定概念で答えるんですね
だからそういうふうなことだから
騙すのも自分を騙していることだから
どうしようもないんだからね
どうそうということしか言えません
とにかくこの経験ではなくて
経験から何を学んで心がどのように変わったかっていうことは
この大変大事なポイントなんです
で それからこの前説明したこのディッティ・ヴィスッディ
ディッティ・ヴィスッディのところに来ると
大体なぜ仏教はこういう風に分析して物事を説明しているんですか？という仏教の理解というかね
真理の理解というのはもうかなりそこら辺で理解するんです
それから実体的な概念も結構なくなっちゃうんですね
ものはあるんだ あるんだということもなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで初めて お釈迦様がおっしゃる通りですよと自分で納得いくんですね
だからこれマインドコントロールされてわかったようなふりをしたっても
これ心の中には全然関係ないんですね
だからこの四聖諦やら無常やら
そういうものをとことん教えて
マインドコントロールするということはとても簡単ですから
他の教えよりはこの方が一番簡単なんです
なぜならば言っていることは事実ですから
本人がほんのちょっとほんのちょっと疑って調べたっても
同じ情報しか叩き込まれた情報しか入りませんだから
マインドコントロールなんかはとてもしやすいんですけど
だからそれで心が変わるかというと心は変わらないんですよ
そういうことだから この自分で見て自分で発見するということはどうしても必要なんです
ですから このまあ最初は瞑想して心を落ち着けたところで
このヴィパッサナーに行きます
ヴィパッサナーに行く場合は
本人の仕事はただ確認して確認していくだけなんですけど
物事を確認するためにはやっぱり能力っていうものが必要なんですね
認識ということは必要なんですね
個別分別能力 だから分別能力を育てなさいと言っても意味がない
とにかく確認して その瞬間
その瞬間確認していってくださいと
そこで集中力と知恵が開発していくならば
我々にはより明確に より鮮明に物事を確認できるんです
ですから このチェックするのはこの確認の能力なんですね
何を確認しているんですかと
それで体の感覚 ヴィパッサナー
純粋ヴィパッサナーの場合は体の感覚から始まります
で サマタからしっかりと瞑想の世界に入る場合は
まあ他のものの観察もできます
で サマタの場合は最初に集中力を育てますから
もう何でも見られますね
見ようとすれば まあとにかく
ヴィパッサナーだけのことを説明すると
我々は一応感覚というヴェーダナーというところから瞑想が始まるんですね
で 悟るぐらいの正直な人
悟られるというのは正直じゃないかっていうぐらいのことなんですけども
で それぐらい正直な気持ちがあるんだったらね
自分を観察するだけで
すぐそんにもうその知恵の量りがもうみるみるうちに
かな もうすっごい強烈な勢いで成長していくんです
これ何 10年もかかるということは
正直じゃないということなんです
で だからその問題はお釈迦様大変この
考えたことで まあどうしようもないという人の場合は
こういうまあマーヤとかサティとかね
まあそういう心が心の中でまあ事前的に陰畜だったらもうお釈迦様にさえもどうしようもないんですね
ですから このまあ正直に感覚だけ見て
あの正直に見るっていうことは意味がないんだけど
まあ心はもともと正直だったら感覚だけ見ると
そこから瞬時に仏教でおっしゃっているヴィパッサナーの世界が始まるんです
なぜならば 感覚さえなければ私がいるということはないんですね
だから私がいるという概念が感覚から生まれてくるものなんですね
感覚は六つありますけど
眼耳鼻舌身に変わる感覚は六つなんですけど
まあそれは適当にもう観察すればよろしいし
で 体に感覚があるんだからこそ
私がいるんだということが出てくる
それで私は物事を見ているんだと
私はいろんな欲望をしているんだと希望しているんだと願望しているんだと威張っているんだっていうことのすべて私がいるんだから出てくるもので
私がいるという概念がどこから出てくるのかというと
感覚から出てくるんですよ
とても簡単単純なものなんです
体の感覚なければ 心の感覚なければそんなことは出てこないんだから
で そこはこの単純なところに行かないで
なんか何か感じたら やっぱり自分がまあああだこうだとかね
お釈迦様が見えるとか
神様が見えるとかね で
いろんなことを言ってくれるんですね
そこで素晴らしい 素晴らしいと言わなくちゃいけない
私は言いませんだけど
言うバカもんたちがいますけどね
もし私に対してはもう仏様があって
瞑想中ではよく会話もするんだと言ったら
私は病院にすぐ連絡して病院へ行かせますけど
そういう態度だから 私の瞑想法に対してすごい疑問を持っているんですね
私はめげません 科学的に言ってるんだから
で 論理的に攻撃するんだったら
私は自意識人として堂々とそれは受けますけど
ですから このあの方法
この方法とかね いろいろ方法を探したりして
で あの人の教えはこうではない
この人の教えはそうだよ
それからどこかのヨーロッパの化け物の教えと素晴らしいんだとかね
それと組み合わせて見なくちゃいけないんだとかとかね
だから我というのは 自分というのは体の感覚の単なる単純なものだということは
ヨーロッパで誰が発見しているんですかね
どんな哲学者か じゃあインドで誰が発見しているんですかね
誰も発見していないんだから
それは発見したのは まあ発見するぐらいのものじゃないんですよ
もう単純なことだから
ですから この そういうふうにこの
瞑想して いかなる あの
何と言いますか 幻覚が起きても
そちらにはそんなに意味がないんです
そんなにというよりは
全く意味がないんです
意味がないということは皆様理解しないんだけど
だからまあ それ本人の経験ですから
まあそれはまあ幻覚は幻覚なんですけど
本人が経験している まあそれはまあ認めますけど
それに何か意味があるかと
意味がないんですね なぜならばすべてはどんな神様見ことにしたってもね
まあ一応感覚がなければ見られる
見られるはずがないんです
経験できるはずがないんです
だからこの瞑想で見るということは
頭で見ることだから 目で見ることじゃないんだから
頭の中で視覚 視覚が生まれるだけなんですよ
ですから その場合もやっぱり感受性がなければ生まれてこないんですね
ですから いきなり感覚ってなんですかと感覚を確認していくと
目が覚めるはずなんです
あ なるほど これで自我が生まれるんだと
その瞬間ですごく心が楽になってしまうんです
その瞬間はこのリッティ・ビスッディなんです
それでさらに自分が感覚だけ見ていけば
それはまあ一秒間にも一万回以上
いろんな感覚が生まれて変わって生まれて変わっていくということが見えてくるんでしょうし
だからそうするともう瞬時に瞑想はまあ
瞬時に成長して昇り降りしちゃうんです
そういう人に必要なのは
この滅ということは体験することだけなんですよ
いわゆる涅槃という仏教専門用語で言えば解脱ということは
ほんのちょっと心集中して
ものの二郎だ 滅することを体験することだけなんですね
ほんの少々の努力でできるんです
それで最終もうもう二度と実体という概念が生まれてこないんですね
実体があるという概念が生まれてこない人にとっては
かなりの煩悩はなくなってるんです
さらに瞑想しちゃうと
残りの煩悩も消えるし
もう確実にそれは消えるんです
今世でなくても 残りは
まあそういうことだから
まあそこでヴィッティヴィスッディの場合は
このこれはあの 今言ったのはもうこの一発の悟りの道なんですけど
まあこちらではこのゆっくりのんびり智慧が開発する方法なんですね
そこで最初にこの確認していく
で 確認するためには知識というか
分別能力が必要なんで
膨らみと縮みは間違うと
もう分別能力ないんですよ
左足の動きと右足の動きを間違うと
もう分別能力ないんです
ですから そこは頑張って頑張って明確に確認できるところまで進めなく頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
だから妄想が生まれたらすぐ妄想だと
痛みが生まれたらすぐ痛みだと
しびれが生まれたらすぐしびれですよと
そうやってごく普通に簡単に確認する
その能力 そこら辺で失敗しないこと
左足を動かせながらもう右足を確認すると
そこでまあずれているんですね
で そういう調子でやっちゃうと
まあいいんじゃないかっていう調子でやっちゃうと
ずっとその人の人格は大雑把でいい加減でしょ
そうすると何年かかるかわからないんですね
だからしっかりと物事を淡々と確認できるためには
やっぱり自我があればできませんし
あまりにも自分の固定概念もあればできないし
あまりにも余計なことを考えたり
妄想したりするともできないし
で そうやってこの物事をしっかりとさっさっさっと観察していく
それでいくらかは観察能力は成長する
いわゆるサティの力なんですね
いわゆる分別能力なんですね
成長すると その分は智慧は開発しなくちゃいけないんです
智慧がないと いくら時間経っても大雑把で何か確認していると
そこで逃げて ああ 私は瞑想よくできるんだとかね
大変気持ちいいんだとかね
[笑い]で そういうことを言ったりする
気持ちいいか悪いか一度も聞いたことがないんですよね
だからヴィパッサナーの方でチェックするのは気持ちいいか悪いかなくて
もう分別能力はできてるかないかということを確かめるんですね
そのやり方は全部説明しますけど
それからはもっと上手に人を騙すことはできるようになると思います
[笑い]あの指導したいという気持ち捨てない限りは説明できません
だからまあもう悩んではいるんだけど
一旦説明してあげたら
それでも指導はできないんです
だから説明しない 誰にも
まあで 一応早く早く早くって説明していきますけど
この例えば私は大体この妄想が出てきて
出てきて もう大変困っているんだと
まず妄想だけで確認してくださいと
で 普通だったら人間に自分の思考だけ
だけでも確認することはできない
で 思考が生まれたら それでも客観的に確認することをできたということ自体も
まあ分別能力ついたということなんですね
そうついてきたっても
本人がすごい勘違いして
妄想が止まってくれるんだでしょうと
そんなものは妄想であってというもんで
もう計画立ててるんだから
こうなります ああなりますと
こうなります ああなりますと思うこと自体が
この感覚から生まれてくる自害意識なんですね
それは悟りの世界じゃないんです
ですから 次に大体いろいろ妄想が出てきて
もういくら確認したって
もう大変だと いうと 大体私は言うのは
まあ怒りの妄想と欲の妄想とか
それから無知の妄想にぐらいに分けてみてください
分けられないという場合は
気持ちいい妄想は欲の妄想だと
気持ち悪い妄想は怒りの妄想だと
ただモヤモヤと もう勝手に出てきて
もう眠気につながる妄想は無知の妄想だと
で 区別しなさいと なぜかというと
すごい気持ちいいことを妄想すると人は眠ってしまいません
すごく腹が立って 嫌なことを人のことやら
いろんなことやら 嫌ですよ
ああですよと考える時でも怒りが出て
眠気が出てこないんですね
脳がものすごく活動しているんですね
それで何のことなく 何を考えているかわからなくて
いろいろ妄想が出てくる
鼻のことやら食べたもののことやら
もうもうもう日常のことやら
皿洗いのことやら もういろんなことを頭に浮かんだりする
自分ではそれは欲か怒りかはあまりわからないんですね
それは無知の妄想で 放っておけば必ずもう昏睡睡眠に入っちゃうんです
ですから その場合は脳を刺激していないんですね
刺激していないんだから眠気に繋がります
そういう雑念は無知の妄想
雑念だと３つに分けてみてください
と言うんですけど ちゃんとやってくれた人はいないんですけど
で なぜそういうふうに言いますかというと
この分別能力を育てるためなんです
瞬時に あ これはこれに
これはこれにと分けて入れられるかと
色性は色に 心は心の方に分けられますかと
そうやって明確に物事を分けられる
何でももうしっかりラベリングできるかというと
このディッティヴィスッジョの方なんです
なぜかというと ディッティヴィスッジョのこちらの説明はラックナ・ラサ・パッチ・パッターナ・パダッターナという４つに見ることだと
で ラックナっていうのはある現象の特色なんですね
例えば怒りの妄想が出てきたりする
それは怒りの妄想だと確認するために
他の妄想と区別しなくちゃいけないんですね
瞑想する前に食べたご飯のことを思い浮かんだりして
で それは怒りの妄想だと確認しないでしょうし
[笑い]隣に座ってる人のことは気になって嫌になってくるんだと
それは怒りの妄想でしょうし
だからその区別できるんですね
だから区別できるっていうことは
今の妄想自体がどんなラッカーナ
どんな特色を持ってるかともうとっくに捕まってるんです
そうでないとラベリングできないんです
だからラベリング重視にできるということは
ラッカーナというものを捕まってることなんです
そこでこの間違って じゃあこれから私はラッカーナを特色を観察しますよって
そんなことはできるわけじゃない
それは専門用語です 医者使ってる専門用語と同じものなんです
患者さんには関係ないんです
ラサっていうのは機能でしょうし
ラッカーナで捕まえない人にとってはラサで機能で捕まるんですね
例えばいろいろ妄想が出てきた
妄想 雑念だと確認したんだけど
なんとなく自分にはそれに喜びというか執着というか
惹かれていると わかったところで
これ機能でしょうに 欲の雑念は人を欲の方に惹かれていくんですね
それで分別できますでしょ
あ これは欲の妄想です
これは貪りの妄想です
だから特色でもできるし
ラサという機能を見てでも妄想を区別できます
だから専門用語で言えば
人があなたどうやって欲の妄想だと確認できますか？と聞いたところで
なんか雑念雑念って言ってるんだけど
なんかズルズルと惹かれちゃうんだと
あとだったら 私はこれはもう欲の妄想だと思ったんだよと言ってくれたならば
その人はラサで機能でファンクションで確認していることなんです
だから人から話を聞いて
この人はラッカーナ取ってるか
ラサ取ってるか パッチパッターナ取ってるか
パダッターナ取ってるかということは
教える側が見るんであって
修行者にはそれは関係ないしできないし
じゃあこれからパダッターナ見ようかと
できるわけでないんです
でも少々少々ではなくて
どんどんどんどん鋭く鋭くなっていくと
例えばこの雑念が生まれるよと思うと
もう確認できる できたとする
その場合はパダッターナで捕まってるんです
近い原因で あ これだったらすぐにこんなことを妄想するんだと自分が
もうとっくにわかってるんです
それがやっぱり経験も必要なんですね
例えば一回鳥の声聞いちゃったら
自分が何かざわざわと妄想しちまったということ
それをもう確認する またまた確認する
まあ次は同じ鳥の声が耳に入った途端
これからこうやって妄想するだろう
すぐわかっちゃうんです
だからもうその場合はもうパダッターナという一番近い原因の確認できるようになっているんですね
だからそうやってこのラッカーナスパッチパッターナパダッターナという
この一つの現象の側面
認識できる側面 その人の分別能力
あるいは知恵の鋭さによるもので
上手にできるということは
知恵が鋭くなったということで
だからそこら辺ではどうしても個人差があります
ラッカーに見える人 ラサに見える人とか
いろいろ個人差があります
だから どんな個人差があっても
修行する人の仕事はとにかく確認してみましょうということなんですね
大雑把ではなくて いい加減ではなくて
かっこつけて瞑想するんじゃなくて
とにかくもう確認してみるんだと
上手に確認するために
その個人が自分なりのいろいろ工夫するかもしれません
その工夫は無意味ですけど
なぜならば それはラベリングするための工夫だから
その工夫自体がはっきりとこのラッカーナスパッチパッターナパダッターナというつつのどちらかに入っちゃうんです
そういうことだから 言われる通りにやると必ずもディッティビスッディは合格できるんです
それで最終的に何がわかるかというと
この心の機能と体という物体の機能が明確に見えてくる
それでその人にとっては何が存在するかというと
こちらに心の流れがある
また物質の流れがあると
その時点でここに私がいるということはもうないんだと
その組み合わせに私と言うんであって
痛い痛いと言ったら私が痛いという概念が生まれるのであって
痛みは心の流れであって
そこに体があって 痛い場所があるんだから
足でも手でも何でも腰でもいいんだけど
こちらにここに何か物体があって
そこに心が入っていて
そこで痛みがあるんだ
そこに心がない場合は痛みがないと
だからなぜ私が痛いと
なんで痛いだろうと この痛みさえなければうまく瞑想できるのではないかというふうな
この煩悩的な思考というのは無意味ですよと
土台がないんですよ ぐらいは理解できるんです
だからといって それは悟りだと我々は言いません
本人にとってはもうわかったぞという気持ちになるかもしれませんけれども
すごいことをわかったんだと
まあ確かにすごいことをわかったんです
だから日本語で言えば
そういうふうにいろいろことには悟るんです
そうやってしっかりと
この数え切れないほどの悟りを得て
ゲラートに行かなくちゃいけないんですね
もうはっきりしたもので
いい加減なものじゃないんです
同時に性格も治るんです
別に自分というものはいないという気持ちになったところで落ち着いていられるでしょうに
喧嘩したり怒ったりすることはなくなっちゃるでしょうに
すごく欲張ったりすることもなくなるでしょうに
あんまり悩んだり苦しんだりすることも
まあもう消えていっちゃうんです
世俗的なレベルでは それからそれでも悩み
苦しみがありますからね
まだ悟ってないんだから
そこはわかるんですね
やっぱり自我がないんだけどね
やっぱり自分がいろいろ悩んだり苦しんだりするんじゃないかなと
やっぱりどこかで自分がまあまだまだ自我ないっていうことは経験してないんだということまでわかります
じゃあ一応そのふうにこのディッティビスッディ段階
見性定という段階というのは
ナームとルーパは何ものかと
いわゆる自分というもの
ナームとルーパで出てきているんだと
ナーム自体が流れていて
物質自体が流れていてというところでわかって
その区別するためには大体ラッカーナスパッチパッターナパダッターナというつの方法で一つの現象を見るんですね
ラッカーナは特徴 カッサは作用
パッチパッターナは現状
パダッターナは直接原因
[笑い]それからこの見る世界では
ある現象は特徴で発見できますし
ある現象は作用で発見できるし
ある現象は現状というのは現れる方法ですね
そのまま発見できるということ
あるものはもう生まれ
原因で発見できるし だから
ということは いつでも必ずしも特色で確認できますよということはないんです
で たとえればものを掴まる場合はどのように掴まればいいんですかと
じゃあ家に猫がいるとする
猫を掴まってみたいんですね
で 捕まえる場合はどのようにすればいいんですかと
その時その時でいいでしょうし
逃げていくおとしになったところで手を出したら尻尾捕まったら尻尾で捕まってもいいし
自分の方に歩いてくるんだったら両手出して体の方で捕まってもいいし
寝ているんだったらそれなりに捕まってもいいし
寝ているんだったら現状でそのまんまで捕まえると
そうやって 例えば近い原因で捕まる場合はどうやって猫を捕まるかというと
今の時間だったらあっちいるでしょうと
大体わかるでしょうに
猫はどこですか？おそらくあっちいるなと思って
そこを見たらそこにいるんだ
それはもう近い原因で一番近い原因で直接因ですね
直接因で捕まる方法なんですね
で 捕まる場合は直接因でないとダメです
例えば自分が猫を捕まえたくなったのは 三時
午後三時 それでまあ六時ぐらいであっち寝て
それから六時半にあっちいてとか
そこら辺にいくら考えたって意味がないんです
猫が六時にいるところに行ったってもいるわけじゃないんですね
朝九時半にいるところに行ってみたって
いるわけじゃないんですね
自分が今三時半にいるんだから
三時半になるとどこにいるかというところで掴まなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから ものを認識する場合は
延々と原因を探すことはしません
一番近い原因 直接原因で現象を認識するのです
例えば座っていて瞑想中足が痛くなったとする
[咳]一番近い原因で見ればいいんです
例えば痛いのは下にある足だとする
そうすると上の足が痛くない
はっきりしているでしょう
上の足で押さえ押さえられてるんだから痛いんです
だから落ち着いて見する人は
あ 押さえられているということから痛みを
まあ痛みぐらいはそういう原因なくても分かりますけどね
直接原因を探す場合は押さえられている
ただそれだけ あ 私の座り方が悪いんだからと
私の姿勢がというか あの体のいろいろ構成が悪いんだからといろいろ文句言ったりするでしょ
あれはもう無意味なんです
私の足が弱いんだから上手に座れませんと
足が弱いんだから痛いんですよと言ったりするでしょ
それは直接原因じゃなくて
単なる言い訳 妄想だけなんです
だからこの 我々 そういう話は聞かないと
ヴィパッサナーに対して自信というか信頼なくなるだけで
でもそれはしょうがないんです
間違ってるのは向こう側なんです
私は10年前に事故を起こしちゃったんだから
腰が痛いんですよ そんなものはヴィパッサナーにもならない
知恵でもない 何でもないんです
ただの妄想だけなんです
今腰が痛いだったら 今座ってるんだから痛い
それだけのこと 10年前に事故を起こして腰が痛いんだったら
立っても座っても歩いたっても横になっても痛いはずなんですね
永久的に だから人間のこの原因探しはそれほどもう正しくないんです
だからこの現象を一つ確認する痛みであろうか
妄想であろうか 膨らみであろうか
縮みであろうか もうどっちでも確認するものをこの特色で確認するか
あるいは作用で働きで確認するか
あるいは自分にわかるように痛みぐらいだったら痛みで見えてくるんですね
痛みはだいたい現状で確認するんですね
原因なんかっていうよりも
でも何回なんか痛み 痛み
痛み 痛みで確認すると
別に現状よりもなんとなくちょっと何で痛いだろうという気持ちになっちゃうんですね
そうすると押さえられているんだと
そこで押さえられてるところに気が行っちゃうんですね
行っても痛み 痛みで確認する
その場合は直接原因で確認するようになっちゃうんです
そのようにこの 第1ビッキリスッディ現象場を乗り越えるためには
とことんラベリングすることですよ
とことんラベリングすること
できるだけたくさんラベリングする
できるだけいろんなものをラベリングしていく
いろんなものない場合は
一つのものでもできるだけ区別しながら分別能力を使いながらラベリングしてラベリングしていく
それでその状況を終わると
自動的にその人の心が心にかなり余裕が出て
余裕が出てくるということは
この分別能力できたっていうことなんです
いわゆる知恵が開発 発達したっていうことなんです
ただ 例えばものすごく時間を無駄に使う人がいるでしょうに
ある人には二 三秒でできることを頼んだら
まあ 1時間あるんだったら
1時間も時間使って見ちゃうとかね
そういうのはもう無知そのものなんですね
ですから 分別能力 いろいろ具体的な例を出したいんだけど
なかなかちょっといろいろ問題がありますからね
控えます まあそこで個人のプライバシーということがありますから
この控えなくちゃいけないし
出すんだったら他の国々の人々の修行の経験から言わなくちゃいけない
そうすると我々には関係ないということになっちゃって
もう他人事になってしまって
大変難しいんです たくさんラベリングできる
明確にラベリングできる
すぐしっかりとラベリングできると
すぐできる それで分別能力が開発
発達している 知恵が発達している
知恵が発達しているんだから
あまり時間を無駄に使わないで
すぐラベリングできるようになってくる